Google order number 11110 JFK ordered
since 1963 anyone that tries to disrupt
the current monetary system gets killed
the swamp exists because the FED a
private entity is in charge of the money
supply you hear the story with the FED
what uh what have you found with what
John F Kennedy wanted to do with the FED
some say he wanted to end it you know
some were not happy about it what do you
know about that do you want to take that
one I I don't know that's that is that's
not true okay that thing about the FED
order all right it's not true the way
some people spin it uh it was really a
technical kind of uh change that Kennedy
was making all right uh it was not but
Kennedy did have a dispute with the
Federal Reserve and this is why he hired
a guy named James Saxon to be the
Comptroller of the currency Kennedy did
not think that the Fed was making it
easy enough to to borrow money okay and
so Saxon became his agent in that he
wanted to sanction more lending for
small farmers for small businesses he
even said you know I don't like the
Federal Reserves uh uh their description
for qualifying for loans and he then
tried to encourage the opening up of
more State Banks that would have
more lenient lending requirements all
right and so in that sense in that sense
yes Kennedy was trying to oppose and I'm
sure you're aware that the Federal
Reserve is essentially represents you
know Wall Street in New York you know
the Rockefeller Empire the Morgan Empire
in fact I think they're signed on to the
actual constitution of the federal Reser
the warburgs and people like that were a
part of of the Federal Reserve and like
you said Kennedy was not from that
particular branch of the power elite
yeah I held a meeting in the room at
Jekyll Island where you know the the
whole meeting took place and I don't
know if you've been there or not it's a
very interesting place uh where you know
you've actually been to Jekyll Island
I've been at Jekyll Island I flew our
guys in
chartered a plane flew him in took them
there show them through all the homes
all the vacation homes how they lived in
this community and what it was like and
you know some guys stayed in some of the
properties it was a very interesting
experience see uh what Jekyll Island is
but it's actually I don't even know why
they went there it's not like the nicest
place if you go to it it's not somewhere
where you say oh my gosh what a
beautiful place for all these
billionaires to have a place to live it
wasn't that fancy I understand some
people's Fascinations with it but I
wasn't enamored by it it wasn't nothing
that I was under one more than anything
else when I left I I think you should
Jekyll Island was the place where these
very powerful and rich people went to
formulate the idea
of a Federal Reserve Bank okay so that's
that's why it's important history yeah
yeah the the have you ever read the book
The Creatures of a Jekyll Island what'd
you think about that yeah it's a very
interesting book a lot of interesting
information in that which I didn't pick
up anywhere else you know yeah and and
again another conspiracy there's no way
these guys have that much power what
they do they don't that's another one
that goes back and forth so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red or
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright so your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]